[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission je suis
très très heureux de recevoir quelqu'un
que j'admire beaucoup que j'aime
beaucoup qui est Morgan Legrand bonjour
bonjour à vous merci beaucoup de me
recevoir
tous les deux c'est formidable alors
peut-être que je pense que beaucoup de
téléspectateurs vous connaissent parce
que vous présentez une émission qui
s'appelle dans les yeux de Morgane qui
existe depuis deux ans et puis alors on
va parler de cette émission parce que il
y a une opération formidable qui va être
lancée à partir du 7 mars à financement
participatif pour la troisième saison de
cette émission on en parlera tout à
l'heure mais alors il y a peut-être
aussi d'échanges de dire qui ne
connaissent pas Morgane Legrand et c'est
bien dommage qui est Morgane Legrand
donc ceci effectivement l'animatrice de
l'émission avec les yeux de Morgane donc
une émission avec également des podcasts
mais au-delà de ça donc je suis une
animatrice non voyante il y a tout un
travail d'équipe pour m'aider à animer
des missions en fait et sinon et ben je
suis quelqu'un qui s'intéresse beaucoup
à l'inclusion de manière générale on
s'en doute avec tes missions mais voilà
ça fait partie de mes grandes passions
dans la vie alors on a parfois tendance
à résumer la personnalité des personnes
en situation de handicap à leur handicap
justement vous c'est donc la nécessité
alors évidemment c'est pas toute une
versatilité mais c'est quand même
quelque chose
d'important c'est une des composantes de
la personnalité quand même quand on est
quand on souffre d'un handicap tout à
fait tout à fait dans des aspects c'est
présent chez moi effectivement je ne
vois pas c'est présent dans ma vie je le
reconnais c'est vrai et pourtant à côté
de ça même si c'est quelque chose de
très marqué de très présent ça n'empêche
pas d'avoir plein de sujets de curiosité
d'enthousiasme et d'autres passions
alors sans raconter toute ma vie quand
même mais effectivement on peut quand
même en prenant un petit peu non déjà
sur déjà sur sur la maladie et c'est je
crois que c'est une maladie dégénérative
dont vous avez été atteints vous avez
été diagnostiqué quand vous avez 10 ans
c'est ça à peu près
à cette âge là où on s'est rendu compte
que quelque chose clochait au niveau
visuel et en fait en creusant un peu le
sujet les médecins se sont aperçus que
c'était une atteinte du nerf optique
donc sur les deux yeux
œil gauche c'est œil droit et donc voilà
c'est quelque chose d'évolutif
effectivement donc avec des paliers et
ça demande de l'adaptation quotidienne
et est-ce qu'on se prépare au fond à ça
puisque quand vous avez 10 ans vous
voyez encore
ça va être progressif comme vous le
disiez est-ce que est-ce que c'est
quelque chose ou à cause je me pose des
questions de béotien comme ça de de de
moi je vois très mal mais bon c'est pas
la même chose oui ce que je veux dire
est-ce que je prépare un handicap ou
est-ce que bah ça vous tombe dessus
comment le comment on le ressent c'est
oui c'est intéressant cette notion de
comment on apprend à faire avec
effectivement alors moi je voyais alors
j'ai vu assez mal puis très mal puis
très très mal comme j'ai tendance à le
dire mais jusqu'à assez récemment en
fait ça avait moins d'impact sur ma vie
donc il y a encore aller disons deux ans
en tout cas je voyais un peu des visages
des gens etc ce qui n'est plus le cas et
sur comment on se prépare il y a un côté
un peu
s'adapter au jour le jour
je trouve qu'il y a un côté ouais parce
que comme c'est des paliers encore une
fois et d'un coup on n'arrive plus à
avoir une porte un visage etc où on doit
s'adapter dans des actions il faut être
très attentif et s'adapter à vite je
trouve qu'il y a de ça ce qui n'empêche
pas que on apprend voilà à se tourner
vers les bonnes personnes et structures
etc ça ça aide énormément au quotidien
il faut avoir aussi voilà des bonnes
personnes et je sais que par exemple
dans l'émission que vous faites avec les
yeux de Morgan il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont qui sont à côté de vous qui
vous aident qui sont formidables qui
sont j'ai l'impression que je les ai
croisés
exactement et ben oui je faisais aussi
référence à l'émission tout à fait à
l'émission puis la vie évidemment vous
aimez vous aimiez décider et vous aimez
toujours décider oui oui c'est un peu
atypique vous vous faites bien d'en
parler mais effectivement j'adorais
dessiner des portraits aux fusain je le
fais un tout petit peu moins parce que
ça me demande beaucoup de
[Musique]
tel qu'il est alors c'est vrai que ça un
peu frustrant alors il existe des stylos
en relief que je n'ai pas encore testé
et sur le côté ne pas voir le dessin et
ben disons que je m'auto persuade je me
dis oh ça doit être réussi
voilà c'est un avantage tout à fait vous
faites aussi de la course à pied oui
vous aimez bien ça oui c'est vrai j'ai
couru en binôme j'ai eu cette cette
chance et c'est super alors intéressant
mais aussi comment immersif puisque les
réflexes l'environnement alors touchant
quand on ne voit pas et voilà ça
permettait aussi de retrouver de la
liberté et plein de sensations donc bien
sûr c'est super la course à pied
alors vous avez poursuivi des études
vous avez une bague vous avez fait un
BTS je crois
comment
quels sont les est-ce qu'il y a quand
même des difficultés particulières
quand on fait des études est-ce que le
au fond le monde de l'éducation et
adapté aux situations de handicap ou
est-ce qu'il y aura des efforts encore à
faire dans dans et dans quel domaine
ce que je peux en dire en tout cas c'est
que le monde de l'éducation évolue
plutôt dans le bon sens puisqu'on essaye
de plus en plus de parler d'inclusion à
l'école et dans les études c'est une
bonne chose après bien sûr il reste
toujours des choses à faire pour
s'adapter au profil particulier mais je
comprends que ça puisse être difficile
quand on a une classe avec plusieurs
élèves mais voilà encore une fois les
choses bougent plutôt dans le bon sens
et donc me concernant ça m'a aussi
permis de suivre des études avec un
ordinateur avec des professeurs qui
lisaient les choses puisque je voyais
pas au tableau avec des personnes qu'on
a placement là auxiliaire de vie
scolaire donc voilà il y a plusieurs
adaptations qui permettent de suivre
quand même un parcours en fait
et quand vous avez alors vous avez passé
ce BTS qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
vouliez faire dans la vie vous aviez
déjà une idée
je savais que j'aimais déjà porté des
messages
m'engager en fait l'engagement citoyen
c'est quelque chose qui me passionnait
déjà et qui m'animait je voulais essayer
de retrouver quelque chose dans ce style
c'est pour ça que j'ai suivi des études
de communication après le petit paradoxe
c'est que j'avais pas tout à fait à
l'esprit que en fait on me lançant dans
la communication il y avait beaucoup de
visuels et qu'en parallèle moi ma vie se
dégrader donc c'était pas forcément le
truc le plus facile surtout pour la
télévision
j'avais pas trop cogiter le truc à ce
moment là mais ça empêche pas de
retomber sur ses pattes effectivement et
moi ce que je voulais c'était pouvoir
aller à la rencontre des gens et porter
certains sujets y compris à l'écran y
compris et c'est ça qui te moi je trouve
assez formidable dans votre parcours
je dirais que c'est on pourrait penser
que quand voilà on a une situation de
handicap on peut parfois se refermer sur
soi-même ça je pense qu'il y a des gens
qui arrivent vous êtes ouvert aux autres
est-ce que c'est peut-être est-ce que
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui nous a
poussé à vous offrir aux autres vous
l'aviez vous l'aviez probablement en
vous mais
l'idée d'être de vous ouvrir aux autres
d'être utile
c'est je crois que c'est quelque chose
qui est très profond chez vous vous
m'avez bien cerné tout à fait ça m'a
guidé oui c'est sûr ça m'a guidé je
comprends tout à fait qu'avec le
handicap on se on puisse renfermer et
s'isoler ça peut rendre craintif et ça
se comprend tout à fait
ça arrive à tout le monde quand on n'est
pas
bien bon parfois on a tendance à se
refermer oui exactement à tout le monde
ça peut se comprendre après dans mon cas
effectivement il y avait l'envie de
m'investir pour les autres alors oui
d'être utile et puis de pouvoir défendre
des sujets parfois dont on ne parle pas
assez et ça ça m'a motivé un peu pour
garder le cap et pour continuer de
rencontrer des gens parce que pour mieux
les comprendre ben encore faut-il aller
vers eux donc il a fallu que je continue
comment est né avec les yeux de Morgan
alors avec les yeux de Morgane c'est une
très belle aventure inclusive l'idée
c'est qu'il y avait plusieurs acteurs
dans la boucle plusieurs acteurs
préoccupés par l'inclusion et c'est de
là qui est venu d'ailleurs le projet
donc en en discutant avec l'équipe et
avec notre directeur qui s'appelle Alain
et voilà on avait envie de porter un
sujet inclusif d'utiliser les
compétences et la technologie en interne
pour porter une émission et donc voilà
c'est comme ça qui est né ce projet avec
une idée une idée commune de porter des
messages et de pouvoir rencontrer plein
de profils porteurs en fait c'est né
comme ça très joliment et on a mis tous
les moyens en oeuvre avec l'équipe pour
arriver à faire vivre ce très beau
projet qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a appris
cette émission et qu'est-ce que vous
aurez appris les avis il y a deux
invités qu'est-ce que vous a appris les
gens qui sont avec vous sur le plateau
ils m'ont appris entre autres et
j'espère que c'est ce qu'ils apprennent
aussi aux autres en tout cas qui
j'espère qu'ils arrivent à rassurer sur
certains sujets mais ça ça prend qu'il y
a beaucoup d'optimisme en fait quel que
soit le sujet on peut avoir
effectivement une maladie un handicap on
peut voilà avoir des difficultés que ce
soit dans les études dans le fait de
passer le permis de conduire pourquoi
pas dans les loisirs mais néanmoins il y
a des solutions et à force de beaucoup
de dynamisme et d'enthousiasme il y a
souvent des choses et des alternatives
existantes et on en apprend en fait à
chaque épisode et vraiment des choses
concrètes puisque il y a des
associations il y a des interlocuteurs
etc et vous avez raison c'est une
émission qui fait du bien quand on a
rien je on va on va regarder un premier
extrait et puis on commencera ensuite
au-delà de la communication qui reste
vraiment la partie la plus importante
effectivement il y a des aménagements et
Delphine tu le disais ça peut être aussi
des aménagements donc vraiment du temps
et des plannings je trouve que dans la
notion du handicap c'est vraiment
capital d'aménager finalement des temps
et de ménager des moments un petit peu
plus
apaisés un peu plus détendu parfois avec
toutes les contraintes de santé qu'on a
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez toutes les
deux justement de cette notion d'arriver
à gérer les rythmes à la fois entre
guillemets scolaire et ces contraintes
de santé
la salle c'est justement comment on peut
adapter une émission sur comment on peut
adapter le temps scolaire notamment
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on voit différemment qu'est-ce qu'on
voit mieux avec les yeux de Morgan
qu'est-ce qu'on découvre à travers
l'émission
oui alors ce qu'on découvre à travers
l'émission On va on va en parler enfin
on va en parler évidemment mais
qu'est-ce que vous j'ai l'impression que
vous peut-être que vous voyez des choses
que que moi je ne verrai pas que
d'autres devraient pas
alors je sais pas si on est plusieurs
dans ce cas là en tout cas moi ce que ce
que je perçois dans cette émission et ce
que je découvre à chaque fois mais en
fait c'est les qualités chez les gens et
oui complètement parce que parfois on
pourrait se limiter et il ne faut pas
bien sûr mais on pourrait se limiter à
certaines caractéristiques handicap ou
pas et finalement quand on est attentif
on se rend compte qu'il y a des qualités
mais extraordinaires chez tout le monde
et moi c'est c'est ça que je vois en
fait chez les gens c'est leur qualité et
oui complètement et des choses
impressionnantes est-ce que il y a quand
même alors c'est toujours difficile de
faire des choix mais est-ce qu'il y a
par exemple des rencontres qui vous ont
marqué
plus que d'autres papa plus que d'autres
pas plus que d'autres mais comme ça qui
vous embarquent pas plus que d'autres
parce que je pense que toutes vous ont
marqué mais voilà
vous vous souvenez par exemple
oui effectivement c'est difficile
puisque tous les hommes parce que tout
est intéressantes tous les invités sont
marquants puis toutes les rencontres ne
portent toujours dans la vie mais par
exemple sur la saison 1 je suis en train
de réfléchir
c'était le sujet indispensable aidant de
la saison 1 avec les jeunes Morgan et
sur ce très très beau sujet il y avait
entre autres Nourine qui est une jeune
aidante et donc il y a un quotidien très
chargé très rythme mais qui est obligé
d'être mature tenace etc dans son
quotidien et cette jeune fille elle a
livré un témoignage tellement calme
tellement apaisé tellement doux en fait
elle rayonnait pendant l'émission M&M
après et moi j'en parle comme ça c'est
quelqu'un vraiment qui arrivait à
apaiser et qui avait un tempérament
assez communicatif très solaire très
doux donc ça ça m'a énormément marqué
c'était une leçon de vie
et vous avez raison de parler des
aidants parce que c'est un rôle
essentiel qui est amené
on va regarder un autre extrait alors
peut-être parlé de ça je sais pas si
vous avez un chien guide mais là on
parle justement des chiens guides dans
cette extrait alors il y a deux axes
complètement différents il y a déjà la
le demandeur de chien guide donc une
personne déficiente visuelle va faire
elle-même la démarche de contacter
l'école où il va y avoir tout un tas
d'entretien instructeurs en locomotion
éducateur psychologue qui vont donc
statuer sur sa demande voir si la
personne est apte ou pas à avoir un
chien guide pendant en parallèle de ça
au quotidien on a nos jeunes chiots qui
arrivent de l'élevage à 8 semaines qui
passent les 10 premiers mois en famille
d'accueil pour apprendre toute la
socialisation de base et vraiment
l'obéissance classique
pas encore mais j'adorerais vraiment
c'est que c'est très cher je crois
l'association qui déforme et pas pour la
personne qui ont bénéficiaire parce
qu'il y a pas de coût d'achat mais voilà
tout le processus de formation est très
très long en fait absolument moi j'ai
fait un portage là dessus sur les sur
les justement sur une organisation de
Shaggy de l'élevage enfin le dressage et
les familles d'accueil il y a d'abord
des familles d'accueil pendant le
pendant les premières années de du chien
pendant son dressage ils sont absolument
formidables c'est c'est chiant c'est
vrai que c'est ça doit être une aide une
aide formidable ah oui oui c'est une
aide absolue et je suis d'accord c'est
aussi assez impressionnant puisqu'on a
affaire à des animaux et qui pourtant
apprennent retiennent sont concentrés
tout le temps et
[Musique]
presque l'air futuriste en fait c'est
d'actualité mais ça a l'air très
futuriste finalement oui on va bientôt
finir par conduire au son de la voix
finalement c'est ça c'est ça même moi je
pourrais non non c'est une blague
c'est vrai que je suis assez éloignée de
l'univers de la conduite mais
aujourd'hui avec les véhicules aussi
autonomes quelque part on peut imaginer
qu'il y a encore plus de solutions à
l'avenir quel que soit la pathologie
qu'on est en fait bien sûr
plutôt
pas radieux je sais pas si c'est le mot
mais en tout cas est-ce qu'on peut être
plus optimiste vis-à-vis de l'avenir
mais eux aussi je suis une éternelle
et je trouve que oui bien sûr la
technologie ça peut aussi être un
vecteur donc d'amélioration et
d'inclusion forcément enfin encore une
fois les choses évoluent on le voit avec
la recherche il y a beaucoup aussi
d'événements sur autour de la recherche
autour du dialogue sur notamment le
handicap etc et puis sur la réalisation
de plusieurs aides techniques donc tout
ça en fait ça représente autant d'indice
pour justement être optimiste et se dire
que peut-être on va avoir accès un peu
plus facilement à certaines solutions
alors
l'émission
avec les yeux de Morgan elle était
l'initiative de 128 de charte métropole
innovation numérique et les copines par
votre image vous appartient et TV 78
d'ailleurs
et alors là on arrive pas une phase
nouvelle c'est la saison 3
et à partir du 7 mars il y a ce
lancement d'une campagne de financement
participatif alors
racontez-nous un peu quoi ça consiste
pourquoi pourquoi il y a un besoin de ça
et en quoi ça consiste comment on peut
faire comment on peut devenir
je sais pas associer à l'émission
financier de l'émission
l'idée donc bien sûr c'est de continuer
de porter l'inclusion avec la saison 3
mais pour se faire on a lancé donc enfin
une campagne de financement participatif
à laquelle les gens vont justement
pouvoir participer c'était l'idée
puisque l'inclusion c'est vivant et ça
touche tout le monde donc tout le monde
voilà et l'idée c'était de pouvoir
permettre aux gens aussi d'adhérer à ce
beau projet donc c'est ce qui va être le
cas grâce à la campagne de financement
participatif sur le site Ulule où les
gens vont pouvoir effectivement
participer et découvrir des étapes aussi
de cette campagne et de l'émission bien
entendu et l'idée au delà de soutenir
l'inclusion et ben c'est de soutenir une
émission qui quelque part se fait un peu
le relais de différents témoignages pas
d'une seule cause mais de plusieurs
profils et donc forcément on met en
lumière plusieurs causes et plusieurs
valeurs en fait quand on soutient
l'émission avec les yeux de Morgan c'est
tout l'objectif d'arrêt c'est à dire oui
toutes les situations possibles c'est ça
voilà on peut se dire et puis c'est
important
presque philosophiquement qui est ben
qui est ce sentiment aussi une sorte de
sentiment de solidarité collective voilà
de préoccupation c'est ce que quand je
disais vous avez le souci de l'autre
c'est bien que voilà plein de gens
puissent savoir ce souci des autres
aussi il y a ça derrière la financement
participatif
c'est de pouvoir aussi
se relever partager puisqu'on est très
nombreux à se soucier des autres à
penser à la solidarité à vouloir
on est tous concernés l'inclusion c'est
très large en fait alors bien sûr dans
l'émission avec les zones Morgan on
parle surtout de l'inclusion du handicap
mais l'inclusion en fait qui a derrière
c'est aussi le vivre ensemble l'égalité
et la diversité donc ça ça touche
beaucoup de monde absolument alors on
peut je crois qu'on peut donner c'est à
partir de 5 euros et puis on peut donner
ce qu'on veut
l'objectif l'objectif il y a un objectif
chiffré de de ce que vous souhaiteriez
que le financement participatif apporte
alors il y a plusieurs paliers justement
à retrouver sur le site Ulule dont un
premier palier qu'il me semble est fixé
à 6000 euros mais voilà encore une fois
libre derrière à chacun son geste et pas
de petits gestes toutes les bonnes
volontés sont les bienvenus mais voilà
pour les paliers et puis il y a des
contreparties pour les gens qui qui
financeront c'est-à-dire ils peuvent
être venir voir l'émission les tournages
des autres oui pour le pour les
tournages voir les émissions en
avant-première va évidemment il y a il y
a une contrepartie qui leur est qu'il
aurait offerte et alors on peut il y a
deux moyens de se renseigner en effet le
site Ulule comme vous l'avez dit donc on
donne l'adresse et puis il y a il y a un
QR Code
aussi
on obtient tous les renseignements
nécessaires pour basculer tout de suite
vers les bonnes informations oui
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que comment vous
voyez les vous voyez vous dans les
années qui viennent
voilà est-ce que vous avez des des
objectifs des rêves des
dans le cadre de l'émission en tout cas
j'espère vraiment qu'on va pouvoir
rencontrer de plus en plus de personnes
alors non seulement bien sûr les
personnes en plateau les invités mais
même peut-être d'autres structures qui
intéressaient par l'inclusion pourrait
vouloir qu'on se rencontre sur des
événements ça peut être rencontré aussi
des partenaires puisqu'on a besoin de
tout le monde pour soutenir cette
émission mais voilà moi l'idée en tout
cas derrière et celle de l'équipe c'est
qu'on puisse vraiment être sur le
terrain et pouvoir aller parler de plus
en plus aux gens et à plusieurs
partenaires donc c'est ça vraiment
l'idée derrière c'est de dynamiser un
maximum et de rencontrer voilà des
rencontres je dirais que en dehors des
délires des plateaux il y a aussi des
reportages qui sont au fait souvent par
des télévisions locales ce qui permet
d'avoir voilà une photographie de ce qui
se passe en France
c'est qu'il y a en fait ça donne
d'autres éléments et puis d'autres
angles aussi au sujet puis ça permet de
rendre compte que encore une fois
l'inclusion bah elle se limite pas un
secteur géographique et donc sans les
reportages des télés locales on pourrait
pas se rendre compte de la diversité en
fait de l'inclusion
c'est déjà une un peu un phénomène
participatif c'est
important donc voilà on donne tous les
ondonne tous les voilà tous les endroits
où il faut se connecter pour si on est
intéressé par ce financement
participatif et un dernier mot vous
quand même comment vous voyez dans dans
les années qui viennent qu'est-ce que il
y a des choses que vous voudriez vous
avez pas encore fait que vous ayez fait
une chose que vous voudriez faire
mais alors moi je suis une éternelle
rêveuse donc mais je risque de me
répéter tout tourne beaucoup autour des
rencontres chez moi donc que ce soit
dans le cadre des voyages ou du sport ou
de projet professionnel très très
inclusif je ne jure que par les
rencontres et par le fait d'apprendre
des autres donc voilà j'ai encore une
fois se tourner vers les autres ça me
semble primordial et on a tous à
apprendre vraiment des autres ben voilà
si j'avais un mot pour vous définir je
reprendrai peut-être très très jolie
film je dirais Morgan Legrand le goût
des autres
merci beaucoup Morgane
[Musique]